we've been talking about this for years
Fox News is a completely toxic extremist
right wing echo chamber mostly
sympathetic to President Donald Trump
but occasionally not but every once in a
while one of their anchors Shepard Smith
would tell the truth he would say what
Donald Trump says in this video what
Donald Trump said in this press
conference is not true he would say what
the Trump administration is telling you
is without evidence and we knew that
Shep was out of place this entire time
but we also recognized it might have
been useful to Fox News to have him
there to provide ideological cover to
allow themselves to say marginally more
credibly we're fair and balanced there
is diversity of opinion on our network
and recently it started getting very
publicly ugly for example Shep Smith a
week or two ago interviewed Fox legal
analyst Andrew Napolitano at a former
judge and Napolitano said listen Trump's
actions with Ukraine are both
impeachable and potentially criminal
fellow Fox News hosts Tucker Carlson
came in and attacked the judge and then
Shep and Tucker got into a public
argument that had to be mediated by Fox
News higher-ups telling Shep Smith
you've got to cut it out that was a big
signal that things were not looking good
for Shep Smith and Shep Smith has now
quit Fox News here's a little bit of him
signing off on his last broadcast I've
worked with the most talented dedicated
and focused professionals I've ever
known they sacrifice endlessly and
tirelessly to get the news exactly right
and I am so proud of them and I'm
honored to have anchored their work each
day I'll miss them and our time together
greatly and deeply so recently I asked
the company to allow me to leave Fox
News after requesting that I stay they
obliged under our agreement I won't be
reporting elsewhere at least in the near
future but I will be able to see more of
Gio and Lucia and our friends and family
then we'll see what comes along
this is my last newscast here thank you
for watching today and over the decades
as I traveled to many of your
communities and anchored this program
Studio B and Fox report + endless
marathon hours of breaking news it's
been an honor
so as Shep says they're contractually
he's not allowed to pop up on CNN or
MSNBC or ABC news for some time who
knows what he'll be doing financially
he's just fine he doesn't have to work
probably ever again if he doesn't want
to but let's go through this
sequentially first of all Shep says it
was voluntary
I believe that strictly speaking it was
voluntary but it was voluntary in a
context where his bosses had recently
come to him and said do not go after
Tucker Carlson again it was happening as
president Trump was increasingly
attacking Shepard Smith it was coming in
this context of increased tension with
the broader network because of his
criticisms of Donald Trump and it's
pretty clear that other Fox hosts were
not expecting this based on what they
said on air there was speculation that
Shep was pushed out by Trump's attorney
General William bar now you might say
William bar what on earth does William
bar have to do with this well it turns
out that the day before Shep's
resignation William bar met with a Fox
News owner News Corporation owner a
Rupert Murdoch it is sketchy but there
is no evidence right now that the
meeting was directly related to Shep
Smith so then we get to is this good or
bad because all along I've been saying
on the one hand Shep telling the truth
every once in a while might pierce the
echo-chamber filter bubble of the Fox
audience and that's a good thing but on
the other hand having Shep at Fox News
as I mentioned already gives them some
plausible deniability about being
anything other than tools of the
American right wing
I think in the net the benefits of Shep
at Fox did not outweigh the ideological
cover that he was providing to them and
especially after becoming a target of
Donald Trump I I understand his decision
to do this whenever he is allowed
contractually to get back on the air
somewhere else he
going to be in a great position to
advance his career not that that's my
primary concern I'm guessing he's not
going to make as boneheaded decisions as
the ones that megyn kelly made when she
left fox news which basically imploded
her career that remains to be seen but
there are still lots of Fox viewers who
see this as an unabashed victory they
hated Shep they would anytime he told
the truth start making homophobic
comments about Shep as if his sexual
orientation has anything to do with
whether he's telling us the truth or not
they see him leaving as a victory and in
a sense for them it may be because the
fox viewers that are beyond reach the
ones that are beyond the hope of being
pulled back into considering the reality
of the facts on the ground they saw Shep
as a threat quite frankly and for them
Shep leaving is indeed a victory so not
surprising probably in the net something
that is not going to have any kind of
real impact on the 2020 election or on
Donald Trump but not a surprising thing
as we've been following for a couple of
years now and we will see where Shep
lands and we will see interestingly also
will there be any you know Trump has
also been going after Chris Wallace who
less frequently than Shep but every once
in a while
will insert some truth into his
broadcasts or his challenging questions
the Trump officials is Chris Wallace the
next target if you look at Trump's
Twitter over the last couple of days you
see that the answer is probably yes
Chris Wallace is the next target